Now let's see the ROB is fixing our exception handling problems. And
remember there are two of those problems. One of the problems occurs
because this divide can be delayed, and realise that R2 is 0 much,
much later. While the add for example can be quick and be done.
So if you remember with [UNKNOWN] algorithm, the add would deposit the result to
the destination register of the add long before the divide had the chance that
R2 was 0 and that really we should have jumped to the exception handler here and
never executed the add. So how does the rob help?
So what we do is we treat the exception just like any other result.
So basically when we determine that R2 is 0 instead of producing a result for
R0, we mark R0 in the rob as, I mean, the result in the rob is now going to
be exception instead of a value. When the divide reaches the commit point,
at that point the add still hasn't committed, and everything before divide did.
So at that point we can just do the, kind of wait for drain, you know,
kind of flush everything, including the divide at this point, and
jump to exit, exception handler. And now we have a stable state for the handler,
which is here. Basically everything before the divide finished. The divide and
everything after it didn't finish which is exactly the state that
the divide by 0 exception handler should be seeing. Similarly for
a load that would here have a page fault we would have the same situation of,
when the page fault reaches the commit, we have committed everything
before the page fault, and we haven't committed the page fault itself or
anything after it. So there is a very nice resume point for
the page fault exception handler. When we go back there and
load a page from the disk we can jump back to the load of the store and
then start executing from here, and because nothing here has already executed,
everything is fine. The second problem with exceptions that we had were those
phantom exceptions. Basically if we predicted that the branch here is not taken,
we would execute this divide and maybe get the exception, like divide by 0. And
at the time when we get this exception, maybe the branch is still not resolved.
So when we finally resolve the branch it is too late because the divide by 0
has already been triggered, so how does an R-O-B handle this?
Well, the result of this instruction is now going to be marked as
an exception in it's R-O-B. As the comment reaches the branch at the point or
before it, depending on what kind of branch misprediction strategy we have,
we will figure out that the branch has been mispredicted and
that we really wanted to jump to this label here. At that point the divide and
anything over here is not committed. Basically we haven't committed
anything after the branch. So we can just cancel this instructions.
They never reach commit and thus the exception here is never triggered. So
the idea with exception handling is simply, treat the exception just as
any other result. And delay the actual handling of exceptions until
the instruction that is triggering the exception commits. At that point,
we know exactly what the resume point is for the exception handler. And
we know that we won't have any phantom exceptions because we would never
reach the commit of this divide unless this divide was on the correct part for
all the branches. Basically, if there was a misprediction,
we would have canceled this divide long before it reaches the commit point.